hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me i apologize for the format of this
video i am on the move and i don't have
everything i need with me i'm gonna be
seeing dune in a couple days
but i wanted to talk about something
before i saw the movie because it's
something that i think a lot of people
still
have questions about and don't really
get and it's one of the main questions
that i get
um about dune from people and it's the
question of why doesn't dune
have any type of computers or a.i or
robots and the answer to that is
multifaceted but ultimately i think
pretty simple so you had asimov before
frank herbert who came in and said i'm
going to take science fiction but i'm
going to expand it
an entire galaxy i'm going to stretch it
out through a cosmos and he asked
himself how would one manage an empire
that was comprised of thousands of
planets stretched out across the vacuum
of space and the answer was not very
well but to some degree the answer was
also
robots and artificial intelligence now
when frank herbert came along a few
decades later he did several things to
distinguish himself from isaac asimov
but one of the things he did was he said
i'm not going to put any type of ai and
robots in my series now ai and robots do
exist in the dune universe but in the
original frank herbert books they are
part of the
long past history there were once
robots thinking machines as doom refers
to them as but they went through this
thing called the butlerian jihad which
was basically when
mankind rebelled against the machine
overlords who themselves were being
controlled by other men
so it's not necessarily the whole
terminator idea where it's machines gain
sentience and try to rebel against
humanity it's more to do with
the men in power of those machines using
those machines to control the rest of
humanity which is something that i think
is shockingly relevant for our society
right now and the other aspect of it
that i think is super relevant was that
humankind was using machines as a crutch
because we had machines it was kind of
just stifling our own development so
after the machines went away human kinds
had to find other ways to hone their
skills and different schools popped up
like the mentat school who are human
computers and the benny jesuit
sisterhood or these women that train
themselves and hone their abilities to
the point where they're almost
superhuman there's the spacing guild
whose mutated navigators took the place
of the computers that were once used to
navigate throughout the vacuum of space
so essentially frank herbert is focusing
on the potential evolution of humanity
rather than muddying things up with
machines now of course brian herbert
frank herbert's son and kevin j anderson
who continue with the books in the
expanded dune series have a totally
different philosophy and they actually
went back and filled in some of that
history and the machine crusade trilogy
and they also continue the
machine thing in the later books which
were meant to finish off the original
franker
six books which were never completed
but that still doesn't change the fact
that the philosophy of those original
six books is that we're going to focus
on humans and the human struggle
rather than having it be something
that's not human that's doing it to us
because really humanity is usually its
own
biggest enemy
right so we see that also play out in
the later two frank herbert books with
the returning of the people from the
scattering uh essentially people that
have left the empire thousands of years
ago come back to the old empire to
basically cannibalize the old empire and
it's always humanity feeding upon itself
so i think that there's an argument to
be made that sometimes when you
introduce
this non-human element and say this is
the cause of everything
it kind of cheapens the whole thing
because you're relieving humanity itself
of responsibility so to break things
down again as simply as possible there's
no
robots or ai in the original six dune
books because
one
it's a human story
two
humanity used computers and robots and
stuff like that as a crutch
and three frank herbert wanted to
distinguish himself from writers that
came before him like asimov and others
by not using computers or robots
and it's also true that because frank
herbert decided to go this route there's
so many interesting things narratively
speaking that arise like you have the
telexu who have this emphasis on
biological technology and all sorts of
absurd and grotesque things arise out of
that
so i hope that clears things up because
like i said that's one of the number one
questions that i get on this channel and
also i just wanted to say thanks
everyone for liking and subscribing it's
been really exciting to see all the new
people interested in dune since the
movie is about to come out in the united
states and china it's been really
awesome to see some of my videos being
shared on websites like av club and
boing boing and i'm just super anxious
and excited to see the movie just two
days away from me and then i can feast
my eyes upon dune thanks so much for
watching guys peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you